faut savoir que c'est les deux vaccins
aujourd'hui arn puisque les autres sont
beaucoup plus tradi de même beaucoup
plus classique le modern art où le bio
tech kaiser les effets secondaires qui
ont été remarqués mais simplement sur
quelques mois je vais très très clair
avec vous oui bien sûr quelques mois et
on sait en général que les effets
secondaires graves ils apparaissent
après deux mois pour moi y'en a pas eu
que c'était huit jours il ya quelques
jours c'était huit jours dans les médias
mais ça commence donc la chance tout le
temps et ça a été ça a été des douleurs
au point d'injection je vous confirme
c'est pas énorme mais bon c'est quand
même tout à fait supportable des
frissons parfois une température dans
les 48 heures qui suivent quelques
douleurs articulaires
après il ya eu des phénomènes attendait
une temps juste quelques jours oui et
équipe qui ne cite même qui nécessitent
même pas de prendre des antipyrétiques
du paracétamol autre chose par contre il
ya eu des chocs anaphylactiques chez des
personnes qui étaient très très très
allergique puisqu'elle avait elle-même
de la noradrénaline sur elle parce que
pouvait faire des crises là dessus à ce
jour on a vacciné un peu plus de 7
millions de personnes dans le monde
il ya eu aucun effet très très grave si
ce n'est quelques quelques chocs
anaphylactiques c'est de l'ordre de 1
sur 100 millions de vaccins on a dû de
statistiques pour le vaccin poil cher
c'est une personne sur cent mille
examiné au sénat maintenant quand on va
vacciner des dizaines et des centaines
de millions de personnes
il est possible il est possible que
d'autres effets apparaissent et on l'a
vu sur toi vous avez un masque alors ce
soir si vous avez été vaccinées je
comprends pas parce que je pense que
maman et je veux juste qu'on explique
sylvie plaisant je vais vous dire quand
je mets pas de ma fille ni les
infectiologues qui donne pas le bon
exemple vous dire pourquoi je maintiens
le masque parce que j'ai été vacciné à
trois jours et quand on sait que les
anti cauri met sept à huit à dix jours à
paraître
donc je me protège encore pendant
combien de temps à peu près on a été
inscrit vous pouvez leur transmet nos
maires du haut débit sur messi côté de m
il veut pas le transsaharien le virus
puisse quand vous on vous dit
aujourd'hui que vous devez mettre un
masque ccc un peu
vraiment ça monsieur ce match a dit non
mais certains n'ont pas parlé rim encore
un petit peu plus c'est vrai qu'il faut
bien différencier la phase 2 de la phase
iii dans l'étude d'un vaccin
la phase 2 c'est la tolérance justement
dans cette phase 2 on avait un peu de
recul et on a eu quarante cinq mille
personnes qui ont été testées donc en
fait si vous voulez au lieu de tester
moins de gens sur plus long plus
longtemps on a testé un peu sur moins
longtemps mais beaucoup plus de gens à
la fois juste un chiffre les maux de
tête et la fatigue ont été déclarés dans
25% des cas de placebo donc pour vous
dire que finalement on a eu juste pour
revenir sur les chiffres
1 le risque de d'effets secondaires
comme il vient d'être décrit finalement
quand vous vous faire vacciner le plus
gros risque que vous avez c'est
traverser la rue c'est à dire que un sur
cent mille d'effet secondaire 5 sur 100
milles de risque de talent qui n'ont
jamais testé la communication qu'on en
fait c'est dire pardon mais quand a
commencé quand un gouvernement commence
à vous dire on va vous faire signer mais
vous consommerez a gardé le mas
oui parce qu'on ne sait pas si parce
qu'on ne sait pas sur l'accord entre ce
qu'il ne savait rien de la véronique
genest a raison on a remplacé la peur du
virus par la peur gagne rien fait et
donc maintenant des dans la peur de la
peur en même temps oui nous attendons
peut-être parce que peut-être que ce
vaccin finalement va s'avérer beaucoup
plus protecteur qu'on le dit quand il ya
quelques années vous serez encore là
pour nous dire s'il n'y a pas eu d'effet
puisque on n'a aucun recul on n'a aucun
recul à ce jour nous vendent un produit
propre du terme et pour l'ensemble et
moi je veux juste vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui on vous vend quelque
chose et on ne sait rien on a ouvert la
boîte de pandore ni rien ces panneaux
antonio vient de citer des statistiques
faisaient une réaction sur combien de
mots
d'accord mais sur combien de temps avant
un recul oui pas facile médiator et
toutes les demoiselles quand il démarre
et qui se sont retrouvés se terrer ont
tourné leur ai dit la parole